vous dites qu'il est devenu violent
rapidement très rapidement au bout d'un
mois en fait on était au portugal et il
comparait sa grand mère qui avait
travaillé toute sa vie à mes grands
parents qui ont été déportés et qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie et donc ça m'a
ça m'a vexé et quand je suis revenu 15
minutes après j'entends de loin à l'est
où cette [ __ ]
mais je dis mais j'étais j'étais juste
là et j'ai pas temps de réagir que il me
met une claque très violente il s'est
quand même 120 kg on était sur un
monstre je lui ai dit c'est fini quand
je rentre en france alors qu'il habite à
l'opposé de chez moi il vient tous les
matins pour venir me chercher pour
s'excuser et mime avait comme ça à
l'usure tout le temps et vous l'aimez
ouais et s qui était bouleversée que
c'est le schéma est toujours le même
amour dans ces histoires c'est une
relation qui très vite une femme était
toujours sous emprise elle explique tout
ce qui s'est passé et l'impossibilité de
partir la peur mais ça c'est le même
schéma chaque fois vous aussi on va on
va revoir un deuxième extrait et qui fit
bien ce côté répétitif l'enfer qui
revient à chaque fois l'espérance que ça
va changer et ça ne change jamais
regardé deux ans toutes les formes de
violence qu'une femme peut subir je les
ai suivis et déjà les violences
psychologiques tous les jours et
physique
ouais tout le temps pas trois quatre
fois par semaine en fait je peux je ne
voulais même plus qu'est ce qu'ils
pouvaient déclencher sa violence le fait
que j'ai pas envie de
faire l'amour est cuit par exemple
puisque quand tu as quelqu'un de très
costaud tapage choix quoi ravir c'est
dur
vous subissiez
et qu'amélie cela était évidemment au
bout de son témoignage elle a vraiment
tout raconté compliquée avec cette
phrase horrible quelqu'un a dit que son
compagnon lui dise à l'époque ses tubes
bouge je t'éclate pour garder j'ai passé
de 52 kg à 40 en deux mois une ombre
c'était c'était
évidemment me tromper tout le temps sera
ce prêt de romain mais même dès le début
je sais qu'il me trompe pas et me
tromper même devant moi
en fait on était en soirée
et il m'a dit tu vois je me levais je
vais l'avoir et je l'avais l'embrasser
et si tu bouges je t'éclate
et ce qui était très courageux de sa
part à came le sait que l a évidemment
évoqué tout où son calvaire tout ce
qu'elle a vécu et à la halle à 17,7
chose qui a peut-être choquer mais je
comprends tellement qu'elle ait dit
c'est que quand on est dans cette
situation au bout d'un moment on pense
au pire et on ici j'avais une arme sous
la barre est vrai et c'est très
courageux de l'aborder regardez je pense
à des femmes conduit leurs maris
violents qui ont un coût le cerveau
vrille parce que tu arrives à un point
de non retour je pense qu'à ce moment là
vraiment si j'avais eu une à je pense
que je l'aurais tué c'est très violent
ce que je dis mais c'est vrai parce que
en fait c'est à dire que à un moment
donné ton cerveau on est des humains est
d'atteindre le point de non retour est
en fête et limite c'était en fait après
ça va me tuer donc c'est soit toi moi
vous comprenez ce cette phase qui est
bon voilà ça reste un vrai star
évidemment un délit est puni par la loi
mais vous comprenez combien sur marie la
nation évidemment mais évidemment alors
vous savez moi je suis issu d'une
famille où ma mère a subi des violences
de la sorte et à la faille d'ailleurs tu
es bon tu es mon père quand elle quand
elle s'en est séparé ce qui fait que ce
témoignage pour moi est exceptionnel
faut savoir la place qu'elle tient
aujourd'hui dans l'espace public on a
besoin que des personnes que des
millions de jeunes idolâtres et adule et
ce type de propos pour que kiel posant
un peu la main si on a très peu lundi
inquiète pas moi aussi je sais ce que
c'est et tu vas voir tu peux y arriver
tu peux t'en sortir par les entoure de
toi et elle c'est grâce à sa mère
d'ailleurs qu'elle a pu sortir de cette
relation et c'est benzema qui l'a envoyé
en angleterre un an à guise tom en mai
exceptionnel merci à camille lelouch
c'est très courageux d'en parler à une
heure de très grande écoute et c'est
vrai que c'est pas tant les campagnes
gouvernementales qui font libérer la
parole des femmes c'est ce genre de
témoignage soit des vanités public parce
qu'on se reconnaît et c'est une parole
sincère bret juste vous avez mis tout à
l'heure les chiffres des violences
conjugales il ya un chiffre qu'on n'ait
pas mis bien portants c'est le 39 19
numéro d' écoute national destiné aux
femmes victimes de violence ça va
l'aider
en fait il faut savoir une chose c'est
que j'avais remarqué déjà avant avant
que camille lellouche façon interne qui
a marqué que ce le genre de femme qui
était attiré par ce genre d'homme là
étaient celles qui avaient des relations
conflictuelles avec leur papa et quand
j'ai été creusé un petit peu par rapport
à camille lelouch c'est exactement ça à
l'âge de 11 ans elle n'a plus elle n'a
plus jamais revu son papa elle avait des
relations très conflictuelles avec vous
savoir quand on arrive dans cette rampe
dans cette emprise là c'est parce qu'on
a besoin d'autorité d'un papa qui va qui
afin de remplacer un peu oui c'est à
l'aide de remplacer le schéma est le
même vous avez raison c'est qu'il ya
chaque fois dans oui toutes les fois
qu'on a pu entendre et découvrir à
chaque fois oui elles peuvent pas s'en
aller c'est que elle pardonne à chaque
fois un jardin à châteauroux il ya un
drame c'est vivre à chalon c'est
formidable c'est qu'elle a brisé un
tabou c'est un sujet qui est taboue mais
il ya des solutions à mettre en place la
france on est un peu les mauvais élèves
mais si vous regardez l'espagne
depuis 2004 il y à 25% du nombre de de
baisse de 2,2 de mort par féminicide ils
ont mis en place des mesures vraiment
très simple là bas mais qui sont
efficaces et novatrices et vraiment très
très très bien organisés les tribunaux
spécialisés pour les blessures et les
violences de ce genre aussi bien sur le
plan pénal que civil ya les poursuites
ils ont formé des policiers et surtout
il protège immédiatement tout de suite
de manière concrète et efficace les
victimes il fait d'ailleurs des bébés en
aura une à un témoignage thaler d'une
femme qui hier puis s'en sortir grâce au
réseau parce qu'elle était maltraitée
par son mari et les pleins de quelques
elle tenait fasquel déposés et jamais
entendu la faune et save montré les
photos sur le dette pour qu'enfin on
écoute et qu'enfin son compagnon soit
remis en prison qu'il avait délibéré qui
reviennent à voir pour lui cogner dessus
de ses cendres un scandale